[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whats up Prof we have a lot to talk
about today so much has happened since
the last episode I don't I didn't
realize it can come in so many forms yes
well Martin I'm not going to ask ask you
how you
are how are
you same as last time okay but let's
pray let's
pray our heavenly father it's a
privilege to work for you and it's a
privilege to live in the time that we do
we ask that you help us in this
discussion that we can bring over the
message that you want to bring over to
the audience and we thank you in Jesus
name amen
amen paralyzing times
well M are they really paralyzed or are
they moving at lightning speed
yeah rapid movements yeah some are some
are moving rapidly and some are feeling
a little bit
paralyzed well that's true then the
other question is are we heading for
[Music]
Destruction uh what do you think about
our backdrop here well maybe just a
little bit background about the backdrop
is
this was done quite a a while back
because we were thinking of what we're
going to say and Henry gave us this one
I think it's almost a little bit
prophetic the way it came out yes
exactly because you have the fires in
the west and you have the freezing
temperatures on the right so that even
the inauguration had to move
indoors yeah so it's I think this is a
very good portrayal of what's going on
and what's what we can expect all right
so we know that in the end times there
will be
disasters we know that those disasters
will come in the cities
largely and uh some of these cities that
have been affected have been named by
name yes that they are on a list for
Destruction yeah in the spirit of
Prophecy now whether these are judgments
of God as many are claiming because they
are numerous
articles in the
newspapers and in the media that
ministers are saying these are judgments
by God and that the nation needs to get
back to where it belongs right and then
you have the inauguration of the new
president and everything that that
entails so we have to we have to look at
it from a prophetic
Viewpoint in a sense we have been saying
for a long time that the pendulum is
going to swing oh yeah that we're going
to go from extreme liberalism to cons
extreme conservatism yeah and that it's
going to happen very
rapidly then we have also claimed for a
very long time that the Bible in its
prophetic picture tells us that the
United States the second beast of
Revelation chapter
13 is going to become prescriptive m
and uh that it will use numerous
measures to further the aims of the
papacy yeah and there is no doubt that
the papacy is the King of the
North and that he plans his strategies
over
Millennia and the time of the end Martin
started in
1798 and that is when the French
Revolution got rid of the existing
[Music]
government uh organizations that you had
the kings were gone and you went over to
democracy the final step before tyranny
said Aristotle
[Laughter]
already very interesting and then you
had the Beast out of the bottomless pit
rising up with his anti-biblical
philosophy the French
Revolution and then France gifting the
Statue of Liberty which is the statue of
the god Mitra and also a double as a
goddess because of the androgenic
nature and that this
Freedom would also bring freedom from
the law of God so do what thou Wilt
becomes the whole of the
law that's where Freemasonry jumps in
yeah and you have aliser Crowley and
then you have uh the movement towards
liberalism free freedom to do what thou
wit free sex free drugs free this free
that
Etc and without consequence well there
is always consequence but without um
legislative consequence let's put it
that way then you had the hippie
movement mhm and all the great music
events that took place the change of the
music scene to
straightforward Satanism
blasphemy and uh the world seemed to be
running over a
precipice and then you had the woke
scene yeah and uh the women were
targeted it
seems not the men no not the because if
a woke guy had to get into a men's team
I don't think there'd be much left of
him after after a game so they targeted
the women and the women started
complaining then they had dual
restrooms and you had all the calamities
that took place in that and uh then you
had the mass
migrations and and the criminals moving
into the country terrorizing people
killing people molesting people raping
people Martin if you permit all those
things isn't the World a Stage oh for
sure because if you let that go and
everybody shout want it to happen it is
actually a
ridiculous can you let the P pendulum
swing so far in One Direction that it
becomes intolerable and inevitable that
it must swing in the other direction
yeah is that possible that's the plan
now I just want to know from you was the
papacy involved at every level yes every
single one didn't the Cardinals of the
United States lead the gay parades yeah
so they walk in front mhm what happened
that St John's the so-called Divine
which is a blasphemy to call something
like
yeah uh where they had you know all the
animals that are being you know
consecrated and or the depictions of the
destructions that will take place in the
architecture of that
building all of it sort of in plain
sight you had Pope Francis that well he
backtracked a little bit on on it but he
said that it was um okay it was
acceptable acceptable to bless uh
same-sex marriages yes now you know uh
Shakespeare I remember from my childhood
we had to learn poems of by heart and
some of them I still vaguely remember
one comes to
mind uh that supposedly Shakespeare
penned but uh the probability is high
that it was s Francis Bacon the rosac
Cru
uh who was doing the Jesuit bedding to
bring Jesuit theater to uh England
because the Jesuits were banned and what
better way to infiltrate the minds than
through Jesuit theater they're very good
at it yeah we're going to talk about
that a little bit and uh with all his
occult knowledge he he could you know
swing the minds and one of them was
all the world's a stage and all the men
and women merely
players they have their exits and their
entrances and then he goes through you
know the various stages at first the
infant muing and puking in the nurse's
arm and then the whining school boys
creeping like snail unwillingly to
school and he carries on and he goes
through all the stages and he says all
the world's a
stage but if you believe in Jesuit
theater then it really is a stage yeah
and some of these people have their
exits and they have their
entrances and they get rewarded for what
they have done yeah and normally they
end up in the
Vatican isn't it amazing that I think it
it's every time every time right and
isn't it amazing that
Biden who who played his role as the
cognitively impaired one pretty well I
think was it real was it fake why was he
able to be so loosened at some times and
so you know out of it at other times
what made him go and visit the
pope just just towards the very end end
of his presidency yeah yeah while the
inauguration of the next one was being
planned why did he end up with the Pope
we all know what his stand is in terms
of
Catholicism and was he was he acting a
ro well was he perhaps part of Jesuit
theater most or if not all um of them do
study the theater don't they they get
when they go to to the university
especially the Jesuit universities you
don't you do get study at don't they get
rewarded for works well done jobs well
done yeah even by um
Freemasonry even by
Freemasonry well Martin are these
judgments of God are they man-made are
they not there have been many
speculations uh I watched Mel Gibson
speaking in one of the podcasts and
saying I don't know was this plan to get
the 15minute cities into into place was
this
something uh why do you why do you
switch off the water supply why do you
get rid of the firefighting teams why
why why why do you get rid of the police
why do you get rid of this why isn't
there a plan behind all of
this there's so many unanswered
questions that people can then they
always always throw the conspiracy
theorists yes they throw them out there
but this is what these people were
saying I wasn't I'm not saying it said
we're looking at this we're watching
theatrical show so America are you
burning or are you
freezing let's have a look are we
heading for
destruction or are we heading for peace
I'm very scared if we head for
peace because the Bible says when they
say peace and safety yeah well then
there will be sudden destruction and in
his augur inauguration speech Trump made
it very clear that he's The Peacemaker
he's The Peacemaker he's going to make
peace and uh he's using the the economic
arm
right now the way in which he
speaks and all of those presidents are
sitting there yeah all the previous ones
all the previous ones even Biden whom he
attacks so
blatantly in terms of policy is sitting
there and Bill Clinton is sitting there
and Obama is sitting there and George
Bush is sitting there and they're
listening and he rattles off the changes
that are going to take place and the
executive orders that are going to be
produced and in the meantime he's just
been invited Ed to be you know a guest
speaker at Congress and the Senate wants
him to come there and address them and
then the newspapers talk
about
2025 that's an interesting agenda that
they had there right oh very interesting
I mean what is it and if you look at it
the phrasing that he used was used by
the Heritage Foundation president and
everybody it's the new gold golden age
of America the Golden Age of America now
M there are a few things that we have to
reiterate and that is that we're going
to look at it in a moment but uh let's
keep this good book to hand because
Daniel 11 in my opinion is being
fulfilled before our eyes I I agree with
you but I don't think think we should
just stick to verse 40 but let's read
verse 40 let's start with verse
40 and at the time of the end shall the
King of the South push at him but the
time of the end started in
1798 and the King of the South which
figuratively was Egypt and
Sodom interesting terms right yeah they
have everything in there just with that
one word you have everything that goes
the entire woke agenda is right in
there and Egypt who's the Lord that we
should obey his voice I do not know the
Lord neither will I let Israel go right
so what happened in
1798 secularism got rid of the system of
monarchy the pap y was captive taken
captive Italy was divided
up and the Papal States were taken away
he lost his secular power yeah and he
was allowed to remain Pope in
Exile and the subsequent popes basically
fell under this new
dispensation and then the Bible says
this deadly wound that he received will
be healed yeah you see Martin the
Reformation had given him such a
wound that he was
bleeding and we've discussed this before
this plann he seemed to have a mortal
wound and general Ricky probably staged
his own funeral and why Martin why would
he get such a magnificent State funeral
if he was banned
forever and a denr it's again the one
that was a joke it's a joke because the
one that was hated or all of this gets
rewarded yes the whole time and then it
wasn't he the illustrious
Professor hiding behind the scenes when
they you know the American Constitution
was set up giving the Jesuits free
access to the United States of America
to
operate and the seat of government is on
Jesuit land right Maryland yes Marland
it's even called Maryland it's it's it's
such a fical setup and there they go and
eventually they have these two- party
systems you have the conservatives and
you have the
Liberals and as the Jesuit Quincy said
they are just a sherad they're just
there for the public eye so that you can
change the people but the policies are
planned and they don't really change
whether it is a conservative or a
liberal therefore a George Bush can sit
next to a Bill Clinton and they can
Embrace each other and laugh and chatter
away although their agendas are
supposedly diametrically opposed to each
other right yeah
and then you go through this system and
you end up with Biden who brings in
wokeism and makes it even worse so at
the time of the end shall the King of
the South push at
him and the King of the North shall come
against him like a whirlwind this is
prophetic now between those two
statements there's more than a
century right
and how will he come against them with
chariots that's military power yeah if
you have chariots and Horsemen that's
your military arm and with many ships
that's the economic
arm and he shall enter into the
countries
plural and shall overlow and pass over
so the King of the North who was
basically
dethroned in the secular sense yeah and
had was no longer prescriptive to the
Kings went underground and became
subscrip of to the Kings through masonry
mhm and they became the counselors of
Kings the school masters of the
world the entire University setups were
changed so that you had from a beginning
of
um religious instruction organizations
to total
secularism theories of evolution all of
those things but I want to
continue a little bit further let's go
to Daniel 11 we've discussed this many
many
times but Martin we need to discuss it
some more because it's so fascinating he
shall enter also into the Glorious
land and many countries shall be
overthrown
but these shall escapee out of his hand
even Edom and Moab and the chief of the
children of Ammon now those were all
associated with uh God's people in one
way or the
other the they came from Esau
so they were descendants of
Abraham the moabites we know they were
descendants of
lot and the chief of the children of
Ammon also the descendants of
lot and some of those will be
saved in other words the mindset that
lot had and the mindset that the
had uh was opposed to God's people they
were always at war with God's
people but somehow some of them still
had that
affiliation they actually knew who the
true God was they just never wanted to
worship him no they preferred
baale and he shall stretch forth his
hand also upon the countries and the
land of Egypt shall not
Escape so Egypt stands for
atheism who is the Lord that we shall
obey his voice maybe not Atheism in a
full sense but in terms of obedience
yeah but he shall have power over the
treasures of gold and and of silver and
over all the precious things of Egypt MH
so he rules the
economy the King of the North rules the
economy no wonder all the the oligarchs
had to go and see the pope right
yeah it's always the same and AR they
not prominent now that even Biden is
saying we're heading for an
oligarchy
okayy and the libyans and the Ethiopians
shall be at his steps so M all of these
will obey
him but there's something that bugs him
and that is Tidings out of the East and
out of the north now the north is where
the Throne of God is and the East is
from where the Son of God will come with
all his myriads of angels so the Three
Angels messages are a thorn in his side
yeah doesn't like to hear about the
coming of Christ because he wants to set
up an Earthly Kingdom and he has duped
some into believing into an Earthly
Millennium of prosperity although he is
a millennialism he'll rule forever he's
another
God arrogant right
yeah so these will trouble him therefore
he shall go forth with great Fury to
destroy and utterly to make away many
but there is a destruction coming
paralyzing times yeah he will attack
God's people he will set up the mark of
the beast through his
agent the image of the Beast which is
United States and church and state
combined and he will go out to get rid
of the L vestage of those that believe
in God and then he shall plant his
Tabernacle of his Palace between the
seas in the glorious holy mountain he
shall come to his end and None Shall
help him when he attacks that glorious
holy
mountain well which is God's kingdom
it's just during that time that the
great Fury to destroy God's people maybe
it's just important to realize
that it will be as if it's a Godly
movement of course it's a deception so
now
who were the
speakers at the inauguration who was the
first
one in a theological sense to enter upon
the stage at the inauguration wasn't it
Cardinal Dolan
yeah that's a fascinating man as I say
he has many liberal sides to him and now
he's playing this very uh cheerful
conservative so he can decide which one
and even the the evening before the
inauguration when they had the fireworks
yes they were praying a Maria the guy
sang that again so the whole scene was
set already for well actually you can
see who's behind the all uh running it
yes all right now let's just reiterate
something
protestantism
separated from Catholicism
the
95 points that Martin Luther wrote were
all directed
against
indulgences now indulgences have to do
with purgatory and people need to
understand this they don't get
it
purgation Purgatory the paying for sins
already forgiven yeah
is a Greek
philosophy it is not biblical in fact it
is the antithesis of what the Bible says
it is 100% Antichrist yeah it negates
Jesus Christ because the Bible says that
Jesus Paid the price for everyone he
paid the price Purgatory says you pay
the price yeah it's a lie
he saved us through his blood read the
first chapter of Ephesians we are saved
through his blood and this is by Grace
he took upon
himself the penalty that is my
due we were
aliens we were walking in the way of
Cain we were
Sinners and God while we were yet
sinners died for us MH and paid the
price and what if I had been the only
sinner on
Earth my sin would have killed the Son
of God yes he would still have died for
you that that to me is such a
mindboggling you canot even fathom it my
sin would have killed the Son of
God he took the pr price upon them he
took it upon himself the
penalty and through his blood we are
healed Purgatory is bloodless yeah it
denies the atonement it says Christ
never died for you the blood was shed
yes but it wasn't shed for you you will
bear your own
penalty and that is purgatory and the
only one who can relieve you from that
penalty is the pope yes and he he can do
it through an Indulgence so if you have
been faithful and have been watching his
tweets then I get an Indulgence now
Martin that settles it for me because
I've watched these tweets do I then
qualify that according to them yes yeah
but it's useless but you see that's how
and then people come and say yes but the
they not the Catholic system is not the
same anymore because
since this is exactly what Luther was
stood against let's make it quite
clear the
issue is not whether you do good things
and say good things and do some things
which seem biblical or not the issue is
the centrality of Christ and salvation
in him and Catholicism by its doctrine
of purgatory denies the
atonement if they don't get R of the
doctrine of purgatory they are
Antichrist they are against the gospel
they have another gospel and it is a lie
yeah any Protestant mhm let's make it
quite clear that says it's good enough
to do the good things and it doesn't
matter that they deny the atonement and
Jesus Christ and salvation in him
is part of their sin he has aligned
thems with that sin so when the speakers
come onto the stage being very direct
now and whether that first
speaker is a after Dolan of course or
whether that first one is a
rabbi because I have a Judea Christian
culture yeah what do we have is in a
Judea Christian
culture the only thing that we have
common is that we have the same Old
Testament but the one is based on a
sacrificial system that is fulfilled in
Christ and the other one is waiting for
Christ so it's not the same I have
nothing nothing in common with anyone
who denies the efficacy of the atonement
in Jesus Christ
I have nothing in common with them
nothing and I cannot sit at the same
table and say I'm worshiping the same
God because they're still waiting for
someone to come and save
them next comes the
charismatic charismatic preacher
preaching about Unity unity and unity
that's all that matters what a wonderful
thing it is that the abrahamic Accord
has been put in place that people are
joining up joining up with what with
those who deny their
atonement those who deny salvation in
Christ and the last speaker again will
be a Roman
Catholic and there you have this
wonderful feeling of unity and they're
talking against the things that are
wrong yeah desperately wrong in the
world and it sounds so good yes because
the focus is away from Jesus yes they
they name Jesus and everything is about
Jesus and the love of Jesus but actually
what he requires is just negated okay
and if he says I do not know you but
haven't we done all of this in your name
we've even had Unity because that is a
sort of FAL I not know you because you
practice anomia against the law
now
Martin the Old Testament is also called
the
law and that law shows the sacrificial
system and the shedding of blood because
without the shedding of blood there's no
forgiveness of sins so the whole
thing is a Shad yeah now imagine Martin
in society you straighten out everything
that is now apparently
skew so there they stand
isn't it amazing that they dress more or
like less like they would when they
visit the pope
yeah the only thing that's missing is
the
veil well if I'm not mistaken I'm
talking under correction now but the
previous inaugurations they weren't
dressed in black no but this is very
fascinating to me and he gets onto that
stage and he makes that speech and he is
so direct he
is acting on behalf of the King of the
North
yeah he's saying this has gone far
enough we are reversing it and I'm going
to sign executive orders on this very
day and he does it
publicly and one executive order after
another is signed there are only two
Sexes God created the
male and female the United States will
recognize two Sexes and so you carry on
and every now and then you'll have a lap
dog barking and saying no no you
shouldn't give this up and you shouldn't
give that up and then you must have the
strong arm saying you know even if it's
a women woman preacher you will tell her
you will not saying that it's a very bad
thing that you are doing Etc even the
pope came out and said when he heard
this this border executive orders that
if that is true he is totally against it
and all of this so all of these
executive
orders any logical
person will say that's common
sense yeah and he said it he said it in
so many words he said this is all common
sense he said it's bringing logic back
into bringing sense back and uh if you
really think about it
then many many many will have to agree
yeah for sure and his popularity is
rising like crazy right so Martin what
does all of this mean week one of Donald
Trump's second presidency and a lot has
happened on Monday he was sworn in I was
saved by God to make America America
great again two more speeches a rally
and a press conference would follow and
executive orders 26 of them some signed
at the rally with pens thrown to the
crowd others signed in the Oval Office
they brought a declaration of a National
Emergency on the US border with Mexico
pardons for many involved in January the
6th withdrawal from the World Health
Organization withdrawal from the Paris
climate agreement the Gulf of Mexico
renamed the Gulf of America and
restrictions eased on oil and gas
exploration or as Mr Trump put it drill
baby drill there was this too there are
only two genders male and
female on Gaza the president said he
wasn't confident the ceasefire will hold
and added it's a phenomenal location on
the
sea the best weather by this point a
gesture by Elon Musk was getting
attention and the President's Day ended
with three balls and some dancing to
YMCA with a sword Tuesday brought
another pardon of Russ alrick who ran a
dark web marketplace where illegal drugs
were sold Trump called those who'
prosecuted him scum it was announced all
government diversity staff would be put
on paid leave and a $500 billion AI
startup was announced to which Elon Musk
responded they don't actually have the
money on Wednesday Trump called on Putin
to stop the ridiculous war in Ukraine or
Russia would face sanctions then on TV
the president appeared to hint Joe Biden
could be prosecuted and on security
protection former Trump Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo had his revoked so had
former National Security adviser John
Bolton both allegedly faced threats from
Iran Thursday brought another speech
tariffs were mentioned as was the idea
of Canada becoming part of the us I say
you can always become a state and if
you're a state we won't have a deficit
in in Seattle a federal judge blocked
Trump's executive order to ban
Birthright citizenship calling it
blatantly
unconstitutional and the president
ordered documents on the assassinations
of John F Kennedy Robert F Kennedy and
Martin Luther King Jr to be Declassified
that's a big one H the week ended with
images of deportation flights Anthony
fouchy who led the US response to covid
had his security revoked and the
president left Washington for California
and North Carolina in his inauguration
speech Donald Trump had declared the
Golden Age of America begins right now
however you describe the Trump
presidency it's definitely begun the
first item that President Trump is
signing is the recision of 78 Biden era
executive actions executive orders
presidential memoranda and
others now we know from Revelation
chapter 13 that this second beast church
and state United this image of the Beast
will be prescriptive
right and that he will force
everyone to do his
will so Martin he started deporting his
people and the Colombian president
Gustavo pet cave to Donald Trump's
tariff threat off his plane for migrant
repatriation he he saw to it that the
ples that Donald Trump sent mil military
planes were not allowed to
land and he railed on X about the issue
isn't that interesting he uses X is that
you know Donald
musk's X which is of course also a
hidden
Masonic issue we've dealt with that
before and then he got a
25% tariff slapped on him and within a
week it will be 50%
and where will they go with their coffee
and Starbucks will be having a hard time
right and then he said no no it was just
about the way in which it was done he
was going to send his own Aeroplane to
go and take them with dignity all these
criminals now so that was the president
now of uh Colombia now if all the
world's a stage and all the men and
women merely players how many of this is
an act and how much of it is real we
won't know no we won't know but we're
just watching
right and then uh
ruia went and said you know Afghanistan
is still holding American
citizens hostages hostage well they're
in jail in Afghanistan they're not
hostages they're in jail for supposed
crimes that they apparently didn't
commit and Jo Biden made a deal with
them and there was a prison
exchange and uh he somehow neglected to
bring these two that are still there
back to
America so Rubio said you guys in
Afghanistan you better release those
guys we're telling you to release
them and uh they're playing hard ball so
he said you know what's going to happen
we'll put a bounty on you so now many of
these people are wearing bulletproof
vests so basically if you look at that
threat it means if you don't do what we
say you're going to die that's it we're
going to take you out and they have the
capacity and the capability to doing it
as they've shown many many times using
their proxy which is Israel yeah or
maybe not even maybe it is even the
United States behind the scenes we don't
know we don't know but the threats are
not merely threats anymore they are now
real and whether you are an ally in
other words whether you are a European
nation whether it be China or whether it
be Iran or whether it be the bricks
Nations Martin all of these things are
so
interesting and you know those that
belong to the perceived enemy whether it
now be Russia or whether it be China CH
or whether it be bricks uh they seem to
be passing legislation that is so
contrary to what he's doing we can give
an example at the world economic Forum
Trump speech if you compare it to CLA
Schwab or even this president of the G20
who is s Raposa who's actually South
Africa's president is totally totally
different different and yet they cheed
yeah how does that work it's amazing I
don't know and he took the bankers apart
right there yeah the CEO of the Bank of
America by the way that's a Jesuit run
institution and all of these games that
they're playing and in South Africa they
now have the land seizure act yeah I
don't know whether they've read the
story of
Ahab and neots Vineyard I don't know
whether they've read that you know you
have to be very careful before you do
things like that and the other
interesting thing is he leveled the
playing field in one shot there will be
no more affirmative action or anything
of that nature that's now Donald Trump
everybody will be uh on Merit on Merit
yes now wouldn't some countries benefit
from things like that yeah so Mo logic
and Common
Sense seems to be uh entrenched in this
new system and that's why it will be
acceptable to many yeah but what about
that
Unity that negates Jesus Christ and the
atonement that is where it is such a
dangerous thing and we've warned for
years that this will probably be going
this way and it will
be taking a lot of the um sent of people
they want this to be like it now what
how do you
determine whether you will obey God or
not if you read the Old Testament there
is no doubt in the Old Testament that
the number one
issue showing allegiance to God was the
Sabbath yeah that's it you can go
through from Genesis all the way through
Malachi
and what the prophets warned about and
what Ezekiel warned against and what all
of them stood for and what aah said it
was always the
Sabbath because the first thing that
goes out of the window when you turn
your back upon the true God and start
worshiping Baal is the Sabbath yeah it's
the first thing that goes W and Jesus
said if you love me keep my Commandments
and he who says he loves me and keeps
not my my Commandments is a liar and the
truth is not in them and not one jot or
one title will by any means disappear
from the law and here's this arrogant
little horn power that changes God's
times and
laws and Sunday is his Mark of authority
he States it
publicly and Sunday is entrenched in
their 2025 document and if you don't
believe that 2025 the project is being
implemented you can just have a look at
the executive orders who do you think is
writing the executive orders and there's
another thing that's
interesting I we're just talking now
today yeah but that's what I find this
so fascinating this massive talk about
UFOs that we're having at the moment and
the US military uh opening up and saying
this is a reality and this and that and
the other there will be some and the Sun
and the Moon and the scar stars and
there will be things happening in the
skies and demons will be
masquerading as
christs and they will probably be saying
that they are from an alien world yeah
and that they have come to bring us up
to a higher plane and Alice a Bailey
says 2025 this year they will manifest
themselves
so you have fires mhm and people are
screaming we must turn back to God yeah
well you remember the Golden Globes that
that ws were just before this and then
they had the whole scene there where
they said that uh the popularity of God
in Hollywood was Zero there was Zero
votes for God and all of these other
things and then people are again
bringing it back to just after that the
fires broke out so correct very
interesting all right cast and crew are
leading the way with 11 mentions moms
are holding strong with three
shoutouts God creator of the universe
zero
mentions and Mario Lopez host of Access
Hollywood
won all
right no surprise in this Godless town
and then you have video shows where you
have bad gos that now sudden turn into
Bible girls yeah young girls that they
even prayed at um the Trump rally
correct why are comedians trending
towards
Catholicism one quirky comic offers a
surprising
explanation he says I was Discerning
Christianity and sort of Leaning
Protestant but I stepped into a Catholic
Church one afternoon and I finally just
gave into this compulsion and I had an
experience with our heavenly mother Mary
she reached out and touched me he
described and I wept the hardest I've
ever wept so he sees the Virgin
Mary signs and wonders mhm and then
Martin they mention all the other
celebrities that have turned Catholic
yeah and Comedians and and
comedians now Martin I'm important is it
that we know what happens to those that
die you can see exactly what happens if
you have the wrong
idea you will believe that Mary can
appear to you now Mar if the dead know
nothing and that they will not awake
until they hear the voice of the Son of
God at the second coming that is
absolutely crystal clear in the Bible
unless you want to
believe that Mary was conceived
immaculately in other words that she was
without sin from the beginning now if
God could do that for Mary then why did
he have to come and die he could have
done it for you and me and dispensed
with this atonement right yeah but uh
she was born under the law says the
Bible in other words the condemnation of
the law and Jesus died for her as much
as he died for you and for me
so this whole Doctrine is a doctrine of
devils and this Mary that appeared to
him cannot be Mary because she is dead
and asleep even though the papacy says
she had a a transformation and went to
heaven she ascended into heaven so who
is it that appeared to him it's a demon
yeah now Robert and Marlo will be doing
one on the state of the dead and people
need to take cognitive of these things
so that we are not duped by occurrences
like this for sure so Martin you are
being duped by signs and wonders and
lies and doctrines of
devils and unfortunately all of this is
Inon and comes from the pap system our
people are dying for lack of knowledge
it is
ignorance and Trump's named Sylvester
Stallone Mel Gibson and John F special
ambassadors to troubled Hollywood would
they'll bring lost business back so here
are his ambassadors M this is a very
interesting move don't you
think what about what about Mel Gibson
that is well just before we go to him
just thinking of it it's Jesuit theater
and this is actually telling us we're
taking Jesuit theater back to get the
work done and we will use Jesuit theater
to get the work done and we'll have
pendulum swing in
Hollywood and Mal Gibson is the one who
you know is known for his interesting
movies The Passion of the Christ what
was that thief on the
cross doing with the cadou around him
we've spoken about all of these things
these are these are Jesuit theater
implants and no wonder that he received
an honor doctorate from Lola University
with Jesuit even in the podcast that he
had with Joe Rogan and I'll put a link
into it uh in for it he explained very
clearly that the guy that was on uh that
the actor that played Jesus also went
through the spiritual exercises to play
the role yes and we've done the
spiritual exercises showing the people
where that comes from correct and
another thing he if he talks in there
you'll hear that he's a conservative
Catholic but yeah so he's with uh with
the Cardinal that the pope has just
defrocked yes so he's actually let's say
a a prev Vatican 2 Catholic if that's
his that's what he is he's a prev
Vatican 2 Catholic and modern this is
exactly where it's heading to because
the
children the Protestant churches that no
longer have a discernment between what
is right and what is wrong they are prep
prepared for the sake of
ecumenism to sacrifice the Son of God in
you yeah giving them up getting rid of
their salvation how is that even
possible and all the stage is speaking
about unity and abrahamic Accord and
brotherly love and let's get biblical
standards and
Norms back but let's deny the son of God
and let's deny his sign of authority the
Sabbath verily my Sabbath you shall keep
because it is a sign forever that I am
the one who sanctifies you let's attack
his authority and get rid of it who is
he that I should obey his voice Martin
we are living in very dangerous
dangerous times then just another thing
is Mal Gibson is busy with the passion
too yes and that will be about the
resurrection correct of course you know
that it's going to be people are going
to be fond of it but it's going to be
filled with falsehoods yes and then he
also has these movies that have
Adventist connotations right it's very
interesting and if you take Sylvester
Stallone he's he's like the Super Macho
hero that uh stands for American
Military might and power he's always got
those massive guns in his hands and he
will sort out the world these are the
typ of patriotic movies that they play
for the
military so you have it all together
there it's a really very interesting
times that we are living
in and then you had this little sour
note of the bishop at inaugural prayer
service urges Trump to have mercy on
lgbtq children and
immigrants
now God is a god of Mercy oh for sure
and the Bible is quite clear it says and
such were some of you but you have been
washed in the blood of the lamb in the
name of our God I ask you to have mercy
upon the people in our country who are
scared now said buddy who was looking
directly at the president there are gay
lesbian and transgender children in
Democratic Republican and independent
families some fear for their lives they
may not be citizens or have the proper
documentation but the vast majority of
immigrants are not criminals they pay
taxes or good neighbors they are
faithful members of our churches and
mosques and synagogues so it's a very
ecumenical movement yeah once again the
ones like you've mentioned before I've
got news
for the news news that I have for her is
you are not the
target you are not the target the target
is those that keep the Commandments of
God and hold to the testimony of Jesus
that's perfectly clear in Revelation 12
yeah verse
17 you're not the
Target because this is just a means of
getting people to
accept a new
morality and Sunday is going to be part
of it definitely
I found this one rather
interesting nothing says trust the
science quite like a pardon for an
innocent
man now we've also given his Jesuit
background oh yeah and he speeches to
the Jesuit universities yes and didn't
he get an honor doctorate from the
Jesuits as well yeah so you know well
done good and faithful servant says the
Pope as well because he's he's you know
God's monkey he will try and do whatever
God does but this is fascinating why do
you pardon someone who's
innocent I don't
know I've never heard of that before but
it's like a get out of jail free ticket
for future for future if you want to do
something what does this man know about
gain of function what does he know about
gain games that are being
played what does he know about how to
infect Humanity with
diseases what is it in the
environment what are they using to
create the Fiasco so that they can
create a solution and then Martin Biden
became the 16th Freemason president in
US history the day before he left office
you know for a man who's supposedly
cognitively impaired
he's very
busy especially in the last days of his
presidency he was very busy even writing
how many executive orders that it's just
been repealed again so yeah but you
can't repeal them all all the pardons
that have gone through I know you see so
look at it but he's very active during
his um impaired cognitive
state so m is this a stage that we are
in all the worlds of stage and all the
men and women merely players they have
their exits and their entrances and then
you link it in with there's nothing new
Under the Sun
because everything just and and it's
fulfillment of Prophecy so let us put it
this
way we have said the pendulum will swing
I believe the swing has
begun and the swing is going to affect
Every Nation tribe and tongue and
people and certain norms and standards
will be introduced and if you do not
like them well you better like the
sanctions that come with refusing to
accept
them and uh the military power the
horses and the Chariots they will be
used if
necessary I read an article
that China was perturbed because uh
there was a military get together and
Donald Trump was uh inspecting the
military and they were perturbed at this
tremendous
display and uh was that in the US in the
US yes that just happened so the
Chariots and the horses are there yeah
we know that Babylon controls the entire
economy whether people like it or not
the oligarchs yeah they are puppets of
the Pope that's why they all visit the
pope as well including Elon Musk yeah
he's also been there and this power this
power will be used to the max like you
just mentioned if you it's a golden new
age for America and if you decide to go
along with them you will be on board but
otherwise you going to have sanctions or
uh tariffs that will just bankrupt you
all right so now you had the
fires then you had the freeze you had
the Hurricanes M we will have more fires
we'll have earthquakes yeah and the
preachers will say is we're not moving
fast
enough with our return to God
interesting that he actually pulled out
of the World Health organization and the
climate agreement the Paris climate but
why did he give so much money to Bill
Gates who is the main funer of the World
Health Organization is that's just you
know it's not me giving it it's that guy
giving it so and like you mentioned
before he was so popular at the world
economic Forum where all these oligarchs
and these guys are the ruling party if
you can put it like that correct M the
world is a stage
and this has been planned for a very
very long time yeah and all of these
people that have these Jesuit roots or
well-trained actors and many of them
including Donald Trump had acting
careers
yes so we are heading for a fascinating
time and it is the King of the North
that will be exalted just look at the
inauguration the main speaker was Dolan
in a religious sense
the final one was Catholic again so you
had a sandwich yeah in between were the
Protestants represented by a very
charismatic speaker who who quoted
scripture and unity and this and that
and the
other and now the fires and the
earthquakes and the natural disasters
return to god let's make Sunday
a day of rest and one little group mhm
decides not to go along with it
Martin don't you think the eye of the
world will eventually be focused upon
them immediately and like we've seen 25%
tarff 50% what about 100% could lock
your bank accounts you better accept the
mark of the beast or else and if you
don't
will put a bounty on your head you
better start wearing a bulletproof vest
and we will take you
out and then the end will
come and news from the north from the
Throne of God and from the East I
saw the Our God coming from the way of
the East with all his angels with him
he's going to be AF frighted and he's
going to be like a a roaring Lon trying
to destroy the L vestages of those that
keep the Commandments and hold to the
testimony may God have mercy on us amen
I let's pray and ask him let's
pray Heavenly
Father we are living in very interesting
times and I feel sorry for all of these
people because I truly believe that they
are
deceived they are
duped they do not understand the
issue they see no difference between
them that accept the atonement and those
that reject
it and Lord can two walk together L they
agree so I pray that you will give us
the courage to
stand and to
speak we have a message to bear it is
the Three Angels
messages and we are heading into the
loud
cry where the third Angel's message will
be made more prominent and the fall of
Babylon will be spelled
out and all those Merchants according to
Revelation 18 will be weeping and
wailing for the destruction that is
coming upon
Babylon Lord the antitypical
Elijah has the duty to get rid of the
priests of Baal not by might not by
power but by the sword of the Spirit by
the word of God help us to do this so
that we will be able to stand when you
come with power and glory in Jesus name
I pray amen amen
[Music]